personne fait un triomphe et s'est
mérité le présentera le 19 octobre à la
ferme de bel ébat à guyancourt avant le
théâtre de mogador à paris le 19
novembre voici le comédien et metteur en
scène anthony magnier dans le kiosque
oh
alors la craie cyrano en 2010 à arriver
dans une moment de la compagnie on a
envie de se plonger dans un texte qui
était qui apportait aussi beaucoup de
beaucoup d'émotion et beaucoup de
tragiques nous on était là-bas
spécialise dans la commedia dell'arte je
me suis dit bon pour la sierra danger
très très très envie de monter c'est
impérieux comme besoin pour moi donc
allons-y dans cette aventure donc grand
spectacle ça dure deux heures 40
il ya normalement 40 comédiens en scène
et nous on a fait une autre version
métiers de la pâte à flanc dans le plan
votre nouveau centre et blandine comedia
avoir la possibilité de jouer un
personnage comme cyrano c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinaire c'est sûrement
l'un des rôles les plus riches du
répertoire international
il ya toutes les émotions passent par
toutes les couleurs c'est le rôle le
plus lourd du répertoire français il ya
plus de 1700 vers 1700 vers ça
correspondra par exemple la pièce de
tartuffe en entier ils reviennent je
suis rose mais sa femme monsieur quelle
raison a dit hier mon mari je dois
changer de région dont chaque est
suffisant seuls primo c'est un acteur
déplorable qui gueule et qui soulève
avec des deux porteurs d'eau vers il
faut laisser s'envoler seconde offre est
mon secret mais vous nous priver sans
doute plus de la cloris et je m'arretes
bienvenus l'évêque du vieux barreau
valant moins que zéro
j'interromps sans remords et l'argent
belle au goudron vous avez dit la seule
intelligente chose aux bateaux de pêche
qui je ne fais pas de troupes attraper
c'est tout pour ce vol et tg vous que je
trouve formidable dans le cyrano c'est
justement tout tout tout les toutes les
faits toutes les facettes c'est à dire
que c'est à la basse et un soldat c'est
un guerrier c'est quelqu'un qui a un qui
tient la dragée haute ya beaucoup de
répartie qui a qui a un qui a un
bagarreur un batailleur et en même temps
c'est c'est un poète et l'écueil qui
peut y avoir quand on aborde cyrano
celle de n'aborder que nous sommes de
sefa celle ci avait par force
non merci kenji comme tous le fond des
verres aux financiers se changer en vous
faut dans l'espoir ville de voir aux
lèvres d'un ministre naître un sourire
enfin qui ne voient pas sinistre non
merci
déjeuner chaque jour d'un crapaud avoir
le ventre usé par la marche une peau qui
plus vite à l'endroit des jeunes ou
devient ça et qui effectuent des tours
de souplesse dorsale non merci je le
donne éditeur de serre 6 est réédité
sévère en payant non merci sans les airs
nommé pape dans les consignes que dans
les cabarets tiennent des imbéciles nos
constants a créé la pièce est fait en
1897 au théâtre de la porte saint-martin
donc théâtre de 1200 places il avait des
moyens très importants et c'était le
grand spectacle gros fous pendant quand
la concurrence du cinéma à l'époque ont
coûté beaucoup d'argent beaucoup de
dessous dans le théâtre il y avait une
quarantaine de comédiens en scène et
je ne sais combien de techniciens autour
pour faire marcher tout ça et
aujourd'hui c'est impossible d'avoir des
spectacles avec quarante comédiens qui
tourne dire que cyrano que je joue
roxane et christian fonds géré par trois
comédiens fixe après nous avons quatre
autres comédiens qui jouent tout le
reste est donc on les voit d'une scène à
l'autre arrivée ils sont en famille sont
des hommes ils sont cadets ils sont de
guiche y sont on a tous eu toute cette
magie théâtrale
iliad oui la pointe le mot et je
voudrais mourir ce soir sous un ciel
rose en faisant un bon mot pour une
telle cause pensez donc à manger
après bertrand d'où le typhon ancien
verger du double étui de cuir tire là
deux des fifres souffle un jouet ce tas
de goinfrer de pif ces vieux airs du
pays
odorico ses soeurs dont chaque note et
commis deux petites chaînes
conte avec les violonistes sur scène qui
et qui fait aussi le cas des par moments
qui fait aussi certains personnages il
est avec nous et il accompagne ponctuent
les entre actes donc les intermèdes
entre entre les actes et ils apportent
aussi par moments sur certaines scènes à
l'appui musicale soit en appui
émotionnel c'est à dire qu'on est dans
une scène romantique jouer quelque chose
de romantique soit au contraire en
contrepoint aux automates une hausse est
à l'antenne les marches
je te jure que ce soir ce mois soit le
mans faut pas moi gros succès public on
mais on est ravi
merci nicolas maintenant il est temps de
retrouver un tout nouveau sujet de la
rédaction préparé par lots secteu mans
amanda bouglione et la plus jeune de la
famille du cirque joseph bouglione
si la benjamine fait ses premiers pas
sur la piste du chapiteau son grand
frère andré lui il maîtrise déjà le
diabolo je suis né leur cirque depuis
tout petit j'y suis mais j'ai vraiment
commencé à faire du cirque quand j'avais
dizaine d'années 10 12 ans environ moi
je préférais j'engage c'est plus amusant
s'est fait renvoyer des choses on est
rattrapé et c'est d'ailleurs en coin
j'en vois des massues des bagues des
cerceaux des diabolos je suis un joueur
un peu connus d'avancé un peu plus au
mois de septembre
andré bouglione part avec un autre
artiste james meek des ti au festival de
cirque d'almaty au kazakhstan
pour ma part j'ai jamais vraiment fait
de festivals ce que
moi et il ya des facteurs qui rentrent
en compte qu'il n'y en a pas dans les
spectacles habituels dont le stress
alors forcément après le premier
spectacle abba une certaine déception
normale et après bah ça s'est pas trop
mal passé
en effet james meek leti et andré
bouliane ont remporté chaque médaille de
bronze
une belle surprise pour ces jeunes
artistes qui d'ordinaire partage la
vedette avec un clown des chevaux ou des
dromadaires et des tigres au total près
de 80 animaux mais très généraliste dans
la famille de dressage des chevaux
tigre et tous les animaux à
l'organisation
à la création des spectacles c'est vrai
que les fauves ya il ya un petit piment
en plus quand on est avec un langage qui
est donnée par le danger la possibilité
du dgsn
la famille
bien joué
on est tombé amoureux et puis forcément
sa passion m'a caressé de plus en plus
le cirque itinérant bouglione attentes
et son chapiteau sur l'état psychique
présente son spectacle rock n roll
circus jusqu'au 21 octobre un concert de
jazz manouche avec tchavolo schmitt
mercredi de cette conférence message
yann les 13 et 14 octobre le chorégraphe
abou lagraa présentera son spectacle
univers l'afrique au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le 13 octobre
madona bouglione livrera sa version du
lac des cygnes à la ferme de bel ébat
avec le spectacle pentimento le même
jour le chanteur idir se produira à la
merise attrape le 16 octobre encore à la
ferme de bel ébat vous retrouverez la
pièce de yoann lavabre comédie
tchétchène pas toujours drôle
le 17 octobre gong sera en concert au
scarabée et sachez que tous les mardis
vous pouvez gagner des places de
spectacle sur le site du kiosque
www.kia.ca qui point fr des dates que
vous pouvez retrouver sur internet aux
adresses qui s'affiche alors bon
spectacle à tous et à bientôt
une hirondelle que là bas